مساء الخير هل يمكن ل جهاز مخابرات ان
يكون شخص بعد وفاته الاجابه نعم وقد سبق
اجهزه مخابرات مثل المخابرات البريطانيه
ان تعرض من كبار ائمه الاسلام واقطاب
الصوفيه بعد مماتهم وذلك بهدف استغلال
افكارهم المخابرات البريطانيه في مسعاها
اللي هي تحتل عدد كبير من الدول الاسلاميه
وفي السيطره على شعوب هذه الدول
استعانت المستشرقين ومستعربين هؤلاء
المستشرقون كان هدفهم الاساسي مساعده
صاحبه الجلاله او
الدوله بريطانيا العظمى انهى تحكم سيطرتها
على بلاد المسلمين اللي كانت بتحتل معظمها
وعلشان تحتل معظمها كانت في حاجه اللي هي
تفهم شعوب هذه الدول وعلى شهد افهام شعوب
هذه الدول كان لابد من دراسه اهم مكون
ثقافي في الدول الاسلاميه وهو الاسلام وقد
درسوا الاسلام واثناء دراستهم للاسلام انه
افكار بعض علماء الاسلام
بالنسبه لهم لانه يمكنهم من حمايه مصالحهم
دون اطلاق الرصاص واحده الخضوع المسلمين
ويجعلون خانعين ويكون متاخرين متخلفين
قابلين بقضاء الله وقدره من وجهه نظرهم
وهو القبول بالاحتلال لاطول فتره ممكنه
القصه دي يعني مشكله كتب عنها كثير دور
المستشرقين مدرستهم للاسلام
تجدهم لافكار علماء سواء كانوا احياء او
امواتا وطريقه التجديد بسيطه خالص انه هو
ب يفتح الطريق الافكار هؤلاء الائمه بين
شركات بهم بيدعم الجماعيه
الادباء من التلاميذ يروج وافكارهم في حين
انهم بيحصل الافكار اللي هي تعالى مصالح
في سنه 2013 2014 تعرفت على صحفي امريكي
اسمه روبرت بروس ممكن تبحثوا عن والراجل
اللي يشتغل حاله حوالي اكثر من خمسه
واربعين سنه شغاله على الظاهره تتعلق
بعلاقه ال
قضايا تتعلق بالاسلام السياسي وعلاقه
اجهزه الاستخبارات الغربيه ب هذه الجماعات
تنظيميا يعني علاقه مثلا لندن في جامعه
الاخوان المسلمين علاقه الولايات المتحده
بالتيارات الاسلاميه المختلفه
ازاي استفادوا من هم ازاي اه اه اه قلبوا
عليهم في فترات ثم استخدم في فترات هو شوي
بس اللي كانت لكن كان هو الاول واحد شركات
فيه عشرات بل مئات الدراسات اللي تتكلم عن
علاقه الدول الغربيه بال الجماعات
الاسلاميه المختلفه من او الجماعات
الاسلاميه اللي ظهرت الجامعه الاسلاميه في
الهند وباكستان
للوصول الى جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
وانتهاء ب النصره وداعش الى اخر واللي
ممكن يحتاج الى مراجعه لاثبات هذه العلاقه
انا تحت امرك لكن هو كان اول واحد لفت
نظري الى ما هو اعمق من ذلك الى فكره
استعان اجهزه المخابرات
بافكار الائمه كبار الائمه
وكتب ما قاله سنه تسعه وسبعين في 8 مايو
تسعه وسبعين في مجله اسمها
الانتاجيه قال فيها كلام مهم جدا لكن من
بين الكلام اللي هو كان كاتب المقال عن
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بس مش موضوعنا
دلوقتي ان ما بيقول ان جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين في اصلها هي لتطبيع التخلف
الفكري الاعصاب المسلمين على مدار قرون
نتيجه وكاتب كده يعني نتيجه اهتمامهم
الكبير جدا
المذهب الاشعري
وشيخها الاهم شيخ الاشعريه الاهم ابو حامد
الغزالي اللي هو وصفه بانه عدو العلم
والبحث العقلاني وكان خصما لدودا العقار
الاسلامي ابن سينا
واضاف انه الغزالي
وترجم على طول انه اعمال الغزالي
درست وصفت بعنايه
من جانب المستشرقين بريطانيين على مدار
سنوات
وتم باستغلال كتابات او حرمت
كمصدر رئيسي لتخريب
المؤسسات الثقافيه في العالم الاسلامي على
الاقل منذ القرن 18 والحقيقه انا ما فهمتش
ابو حامد الغزالي تحديدا
الاجابه على السؤال اللي طرحتها على ال اه
روبرت دريفوس اللي تعرفت عليه في وقت لاحق
الحقيقه ليش اجابه مطلعه هو يبدون عنده
المعلومه كلام لكن بدنا
المساله واستعانت بعدد من الاساس
المتخصصين وعلى راسهم الدكتور عزمي نصار
استاذ الفلسفه الحديثه
والفكر المعاصر مش بس لانه استاذ فلسفه
متميز ولكن لانه مستشفى مؤمن يعني ما
عندوش موقف عدائي من الدين ولا من علماء
وبالتالي رغبتها تقول اجابه يعني اه
معتدله وما فيها
خلاصه ما توصلت اليه بحديثي مع الدكتور
عاصمه ومن مصادر مختلفه
اه فضيله الامام ابو حامد الغزالي اللي
بيحصل احترام واسع جدا في العالم الاسلامي
طبعا اللي كان موجود في القرن ال 11
هو بينتمي الى الجماعه الاشعريه او المذهب
او المدرسه الاشعريه اللي هي منسوبه ل ابو
الحسن الاشعري وبيؤمن اقرها تقريبا اي
افكار الاشعريه اللي بيقوم بها ابو حامد
فكرتين اساسيتين
للفكره الاولنيه اللي معروفه في علم
الكلام او في الفلسفه الاسلاميه باسم
التحسين والتقبيح والشكر الثانيه بنظريه
التحسين والتقبيح باختصار الى العقل
البشري لا يستطيع او غير مؤهل ان يحكم بين
بنفسه على ما هو صالح وطالح وعليه ان يحكم
الى النص معنا كده الان ما بيكون فيه نص
فيه سنه او في القران من الصدا بيدعوا الى
شيء لا يقبله العقل اذا تصادم اذا حصلت
تصادم ما بين النص والعقل ناخذ النص على
طول لان العقل عاجز عن الحكم على الاشياء
حسنها وقبحها بنفس الامر الديني هي نظريه
الكذب وخلاصتها انه ما تفكرش في الاسباب
والمسببات
وتقول زال حصل لانه في اعتبارات جيولوجيه
ولا لانه الفائضه اللي حصل ان ما كانش فيه
مناسب ولا انك انت كتاب كل ده لا السبب
الاساسي هي مشيئه الله سبحانه وتعالى اما
مساله الاسباب والمسببات فل يعني قضيه
ثانويه او مش قائمه السبب الرئيسي او
العله الرئيسيه هو الله سبحانه وتعالى
بمشيئه دون السبب الدول الفكرتين
الرئيسيتين عند الاشاره وعند ابو حامد
الغزالي
المخابرات البريطانيه بالاهتمام بفكرتين
الاجابه ببساطه لل فكرتين دول اللي هم ما
يبدو افكار نظريه بحته مؤثره جدا في
ثقافتنا حتى هذا اليوم على مدار الف سنه
الفكره باختصار شديد جدا فكره الاولنيه هي
التحسين والتقبيح معناها ان انت ما تجتهد
شيء الا في اضيق الحدود
انه ما فيش مساحه للتاويل تقبل النص على
علاته لا تعمل العقل 12 نظريه الكسب او
تعطيل نظريه الاسباب والمسببات معناها انه
تقريبا تعطل كل شيء في الحياه وتقتل العقل
تماما
بمعنى بمعنى انه انت
لانك ما اشتغلتش ولا انت غني لا نكتب ولا
في
احنا عندنا اسباب منطقيه ادى الى وجود ما
فيش كل الكلام دا السبب الاساسي فيه مشيئه
الله سبحانه وتعالى وبالتالي عام لك
واجتهادك وتفكيره كلها امور ثانويه مش
مهمه كل شيء مربوط باراده اللاعب طبيعي
نكون نتيجه من الطريق هذه الافكار و ا نوع
من التوافق والخنوع والقبول باي امر على
انه بمشيئه الله وقدره الاف كردي من كانت
موجوده في مقابل افكار اخرى يعني الافكار
دي افكار الاشاره وافكار الامام ابو حامد
الغزالي
الافكار الوحيده السائده في عصره كان هناك
علماء مسلمين اخرين ينقلوا هذه الافكار
كما المعتزله كلهم على بعض كانوا بيعرض
وهذه الافكار وبيقولوا العقل قادر على
التحسين والتقبيح ويقدر يحكم واذا تعرض
النص مع العقل يبقى احنا مش تحميل النص
احنا تصر العقد ونحاول تكون الى النص
وكذلك نظريه الكسب لا لا في الانسان مسؤول
عن تصرفاته وان الاسباب والمسببات
يعني او النظريه ال عليه قائمه القوانين
الله سبحانه وتعالى ولا تنتقص من ايمان
المؤمن
المعتدله اكثر من اكثر الفلاسفه ال او من
اكثر الفلاسفه اللي قضوا سنوات
عمرهم بيحاولوا ردوا على افكار ابو حامد
الغزالي وهو اللي كاتب ان من يرفع الاسباب
يرفع العقل يعني اللي هي يقول ان الاسباب
مش مهمه يبقى بيقتل العقل تماما يعني انا
مش بتكلم على افكار الاسلاميه في المقابل
الافكار مثلا علمانيه انا بتكلم لكن في
مدرسه اسلاميه بتقول كذا وفي مدرسه
اسلاميه اخرى مسلمين ايضا مشهود لهم
بالكفاءه والايمان بيقول عكس هذا طب
المدرستين دول المدرسه مدرسه ابو حامد
الغزالي والاشعريه اللي بتمثل ها مؤسسات
علميه كبيره في العالم الاسلامي منها
الازهر مثلا
اه انتصرت وسارت على مدار الف سنه فيما
افكار ابن رشد وافكار المعتزله وغيرهم
من كبار الفلاسفه ابن سينا والفارابي دون
افكارهم اصبحت محسومه وتكتب طريق بغير
المسلمين او بالجماعات العلمانيه او
بالجماعات اللي هي ثقافتها غربيه الحقيقي
اكثر من سبب الانتصار ابو حامد الغزالي
والاشكال احد هذه الاسباب انه
هذه الاسباب مش بانها تحاول فيه نفس ال ال
السلطه في كل بلد مسلم منذ ظهورها ذكرت
بالنسبه لهم نقطه هديه جاءكم من حيث لا
يحتسب تخيل انه يحاكم يجب
انه فيلسوف ومفكر كبير زي ابو حامد
الغزالي و علماء الاشاعره يقولوا للناس
انه اذا كنت انت فقير فان تفاؤل ان هذه
مشيئه الله اذا وقع على
فحاولت رفعوها شيء لكن هذي مشيئه الله ان
الدول مثل انها حصرت ولكن هذه مشيئه الله
والذين تصلب انتصر بمشيئه الله ما فيك
تعمل كثير عقلك فيه النصوص لان النصوص
واضحه كويسه ومساحه العقل قد يفسدها لان
انتهى اقلق غير قادر على التفكير النقدي
او مش ما يعرف الصحه ولغرض النص في كل شيء
وبالتالي الكلام ده يؤدي الى يصب في مصلحه
الحاكم وزي ما كان بيقول الدكتور عزمي
نصار لان كلمته حضراتكم عنه حفظ السلام
الاجتماعي في كثير من المجتمعات المسلمه
لانه اصبح في يعني سلام بين الرعيه والراي
الراعيه لا تطالب الراعي شيء لانه كل شيء
من عند الله يعني ال قضاء وقدر بل ان حكمه
قوه كله على بعضه قضاء وقدر فان ربنا يؤتي
الملك من يشاء وينزع الملك ممن يشاء ويعز
من يشاء ويذل من يشاء وبالتالي حكمه هو
اساسا لبلد ما هو قضاء الله وقدره ما فيش
حافز
اللي اللي من يؤمن بهذه الافكار لمقاومه
هذه السلطه
وفي محدوده جدا
الحكام وبالتالي انت اشرت الافكار ابو
حامد الغزالي كده وانت اشرت افكار
الاشاعره جدا
العامل الثاني هو انا اشرت اليه في اول
الحلقه هو تبني الدول الاستعماريه الكبرى
اذا كانت بريطانيا او فرنسا اول حق
الولايات المتحده او غيرها من القوى
الاستعماريه زي البرتغال وزي المانيه دول
كثيره من اللي كانت روسيا
يشوفوهم بيدرسوا وجدوا ان هذه الافكار
يعني تصب تماما في مصلحتهم من قرا ابو
حامد الغزالي والاشاعره ومن لم يقراها
تاثروا بهذا الفكر وكلنا تاثرنا نلاحظ انت
كل الناس احنا كلنا بنفكر كرزاي الكلام
اللي احنا بيقولوا كلام الشائع شي اسمه
نصيب ربنا هو اللي
شيء دول ما تقول شلوده قدر الله وماشاء
فعل انا اعمل ايه تسال مسؤول نعمل ايه
مثلا في القضيه
ربنا يسهل وهكذا كل دي الحقيقه
هي في جوهرها هو تعبير شعب بسيط عن افكار
ابو حامد الغزالي ومثل واحد علشان لا اطيل
عليكم تخيلت انه فيما جاء حصلت مثلا في
بلد شيء في هذه الافكار وبدا قامت في بلد
اخر يعني يسيطر عليه فكره ال الاهتمام
بالاسباب والمسببات واعمال العقل
والاجتهاد مسؤوليه الانسان عن تصرفات
في البلد المسلم اللي يؤمن بافكار ابو
حامد والاشاعره الاتي انه حصلت مجاعه يعني
يدعو الله طبعا ربنا هامه وممكن يبحث كان
المجال لكن مش يهتم كثيرا بان حدوث
المجاعه ليس ناتجا عن سبب او تقصير او سبب
منطقي بمشيئه الله و تكرارها في المستقبل
مش مرهون بعملك واجتهادك في محاوله تجنبها
تمر هون بمشيئه الله سبحانه وتعالى لكن لو
حصل في بلد اخر يعمل العقد يدرس الاسباب
ويحاول يدرس المستقبل والسيناريوهات
واحاول تجنبها هذا عقليه وهذه عقليه اخرى
ابو حامد الغزالي الاشاعره في قاسم مشترك
بينه وبين كثير من الجامعات اللي احنا
نعرف حتى وقت قريب نقول الجماعات اللي
نعرفها على الاقل من الاسلام السني يعني
الاشاعره ابو حامد الغزالي ابن تيميه اللي
هو انتقد ابو حامد الغزالي لكن انتقلوا
واختلف معها يضبطوا في مزيد من التشدد في
اعلاء كلمه النص على التاويل والاجتهاد ثم
محمد بن عبد الوهاب الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الوهاب الجماعات السلفيه كلها ومنها جماعه
الاخوان والمسلمين دون خط واحد في
اختلافات طفيفه سياسيه اجتماعيه
يعني تنظيميه لكن الخط الاساسي انه كل هذه
الجماعات وهذا موقف اذا ما كانش اعدائه
فهو غير ونود من العقد تسعى الى اعلاء
النص وتقليل الاجتهاد في اقل قدر ممكن من
مهادنه السلطه في الاسباب
الغرب تقدم لانه احد الاسباب طبعا وليس كل
الاسباب افكارا بنرجع
ومن يماثله اسيره على خطا من الفلاسفه من
اعمال العقل واحنا تخلفنا لان احنا خذنا
افكار ال ال الامام ابو حامد الغزالي طبعا
في فلاسفه مهمين بيقول والله احنا الامام
ابو حامد مصممين ابن تيميه الناس دي ما
كانشي يعني كلامها فسر خطا وده ممكن يكون
كلام مهم جدا بيقولوا انه فيه قراءات اخرى
بتقول ان ابو حامد الغزالي لا يقصد هذا
تماما وفي قراءه يقول ابن تيميه عليه بعض
الفتاوى الغير سليمه كل دا ممكن وجيد ويهم
جدا اللي هم مدارس الفكر ودرس الفلسفه لكن
هذا ليس مهما في ما اقول لا
السلطات السياسيه في كل بلد والاحتلال
انجليزي
للافكار التي شاعت وساده عنهم على مدار
الفساد مركزه على اليهم وهم وغزوه في عقول
الناس و بالنا بالشكل ده حوالي الف سنه
فليس مهما قد يكتشف فلاسفه اخرين ولكن
المهم
السلطه والاحتلال والمستشرقين علقوا هذه
الافكار فينا فاصابتنا لكثير من التخلف
اشكركم وللقاء اخرج الله
[موسيقى]